c'est en plein coeur de la beauce que
sont nées des célèbres petits gâteaux
vachon
mais il existe désormais un autre gâteau
qui fait la renommée de cette région
le beauceron à l'érable petit arrêt à la
cabane à sucre pour le découvrir
reste enfin le moment où on peut enfin
goûter
c'est très très léger c'est très soyeux
aussi soyons pas de crème le pont
beaucoup kremlin voici le créateur de ce
gâteau michel beaudoin les gens
utilisent beaucoup le moi je le suis
aussi quand je fais présentation du gros
saule zighout le ciel à première vue ce
gâteau ressemble à bien d'autres vendus
en épicerie mais avec le sirop d'érable
comme premier ingrédient il se démarque
rapidement on l'est présentement au bar
mi-temps à tring jonction
tout a débuté ici c'était en 2006 michel
alors propriétaire est cuisinier dans ce
restaurant depuis de nombreuses années
ressentez le besoin de nouveaux défis
professionnels une bonne journée et
arrivés juste à cuisiner ou marmitons
jutzet ma blonde j'ai dit je pense qu'on
va laisser la restauration puis je vais
faire mon rêve depuis longtemps que je
rêve j'ai dit je vous refais ringot taux
d'erreur puis je vois le vendent partout
en province
moi je veux vendre 150 bordeaux ok par
semaine pour personne aux deux ça va
être notre retraite
il a littéralement mis la main à la pâte
à la recherche de la bonne recette
j'ai travaillé je vous dirai au moins
une vingtaine d'heures par semaine ça va
durer pendant quatre ans alors il ya eu
beaucoup beaucoup de l'histoire et deux
essais erreurs qui avant que ce soit en
entreprise en févier combier
manuellement comme ce juste boulot on a
commencé avec six par semaine
maintenant on est monté à 1 4 par
semaine puis aujourd'hui vous en faites
premier par semaine en moyenne 2500 à
3000 gâteau semaine bienvenue à l' usine
de fabrication des gâteaux de michel
inauguré l'an dernier
voyez vous un grec de cet ordre là il ya
ce avec un taux de 900 grammes on les
fabrique à trois personnes en plus des
boues seront à l'érable on cuisine ici
une autre création de michel le choc aux
érables fait que c'est une méthode comme
nos mères nos gamins faisait hockey la
seule chose que moi j'ai fait je les
bras fini moi je viens d'une famille qui
était pas au hockey
alors quand j'ai fait de bons sons
érable ma première chose que j'ai dit
moi je me crée un produit qui est bon
qui est plus simple pour la santé parce
qu'avec des produits qui sont sans la
conservation sans produits chimiques ou
quoi que ce soit je suis très sérieux
comme jamais clientèle soyez raisonnable
parce que la santé c'est d'être résolue
que des produits naturels peut-être mais
comme tout gâteaux sucrés très
caloriques mon cerveau et vient mon
fournisseur il demeure abuseridze
moi je ne suis pas un conducteur du tout
que tu as un acheteur autorisé par la
fédération
moi j'achète 6 route de mes producteurs
ici en bauges et une quarantaine de
producteurs qui me fournisse le sirop
qu'est ce qui est particulier important
faut dire qu'on pose une tiers du sirop
au québec donc en partant on a plus de
chances d'offrir le meilleur 6 0 parce
qu'elle est que les conditions sont
gagnantes au bout de la bosse dur et de
production est une des plus longues au
québec on compte plus de 16 millions
dans taille en beauce répartis entre
trois mille deux cents producteurs pour
michel c'est pour ségo râteau pour voir
la couleur faut descendre au niveau du
sirop plus font aussi en descendant au
niveau de la couleur de plus foncé on a
un groupe est plus une goutte l'épicerie
iga de sainte marie de beauce est le
plus gros vendeur si on était vraiment
le premier à l'intégrer dans les
magasins géo puis à l'offrir au public
on a fait de grandes dégustations
puis les gens commencent à elle qu'on
ait maintenant un incontournable
actuellement on est à peu près entre
5,55 points devant et notre objectif
futur dans les 12 prochains mois ou
gratins d'entre 200 à lait 250 nouveaux
clients dans la province de québec dès
le mois prochain
ces gâteaux seront disponibles un peu
partout sur le territoire québécois
c'est michel voulait aborder la retraite
en vendant 150 gâteau par semaine on
peut dire qu'il a raté sa cible
c'est quoi votre plus grande fierté
aujourd'hui c'est un bon sens
[Musique]
on